pink took a stand against books that
aren't banned but the singer gets
wrecked by a simple fact check the
annoying artist known as pink gave away
2,000 supposedly banned books at her
Florida concerts this week confusing her
fans as they're mostly illiterate the
square jaw songstress claimed on X that
several titles including To Kill a
Mockingbird and catch on the Ry are
banned in the Sunshine State but X
called her out on her crap and posted a
community note saying the list had been
proven false and they're not banned not
at all and the only books Floridians
want out of school libraries are so
perverted they're on the reading list
for To Catch a
Predator but pink still doubled down
posting this the Maga cult is mad and
their panties are in quite a bunch well
that just shows you how much she knows
about the Maga crowd they don't even
wear
underwear oh yeah there you go he's
going commando in the back row but magot
is the new catchall for anybody who Prov
proves a liberal wrong on the facts of
course she went on quote I wish I could
continue cuz y all cuz y'all I'm just
getting started but I got to read my
kids a bedtime story about how it's okay
that some families have two dads well
that's so cringey I bet kids wish they
had two dads
too but all this makes me think of what
of my favorite Pink songs get the party
started you know although it sounds a
little different than I remember get
this party started on a Saturday night
everybody's waiting for me to arrive
sending out the message to all of my
friends we'll be looking flashy in my
Mercedes Benz I cut my own hair and it
really doesn't look very good I'm
sorry she has not aged well Julie but
you have you know I never like saying
celebrities should stay in their Lane
and stick to singing or telling jokes so
can you do it
I think she should never talk about woke
books at a concert first of all I can
barely get my kids to read so then you
get your kids to a concert and you
expect them to open up a book and it's
got to be about gays and trans what does
that have to do with singing it's the
same thing as taking a KNE at football
game it's not about politics it's about
going to see people play football which
I can't stand football so I I wouldn't
go but a concert I mean who the hell is
she trying to teach her children or our
children our children don't need that
this is what happen happens when stars
see the glow in their life fading and
they start getting desperate and the
best way to get some kind of resurgence
in there in credibility is virtue
signaling and she's really bad at it
Professor what did you make of it well
they are bad at it because they just
want to redefine what the word Banning
means that's true you know and that's
what it's all about books aren't being
banned it it's parents are complaining
that there's inappropriate books in the
school libraries you know and K through
12 shouldn't have pornography you know
especially we don't have lord of flies
in K through five and so what the books
they're trying to put in are ones that
we would never read to our children
however they're the ones that did try
and get Dr Seuss banned and cancelled
and they're the ones that are having
American Classics be Rewritten because
there's so many trigger words in there
so true they they just they don't know
what they're talking about and they
should be more concerned about the 133%
of students that don't know American
history uh that can't read write or or
do mathematics you just had Oregon
announced that they're doing away with
all graduating standards of proficiency
levels like let's be more concerned
about that and the fact that our
education system has collapsed than fake
book bins that's what I think
exactly Kat you are in favor of book
bands I was surprised as a
Libertarian okay um well look I I
actually have throughout the years had
issu issues with some of Ronda sanz's
pieces of legislation as a free speech
absolutist and so because of that also
nothing makes me more frustrated than to
see someone coming out and saying things
that are completely not true because
then it t makes it more difficult for
those things to be taken seriously when
I say them she was saying that to
killing Mockingbird was completely
banned Diary of Anne Frank was
completely banned which is just not true
and then she turns and goes oh MAA
people are metad no you're wrong and
like like Julie said she's handing out
these books at a concert that is really
weird that is very to go to a concert
which her songs are about get the party
started and someone hand you a copy of
the Diary of an Frank yeah like it's an
important book for many reasons but it
doesn't make me want to dance yeah what
is it get the Nazi party started what a
she's
anti-semitic that's what you
said I didn't say that somebody else
said that Jamie you said that wow yeah I
don't even remember um did you ever read
to your kids yeah I I read I'll read to
them all a lot sometimes what did you
read to them um well I'll tell you what
I was going to read them and I'll pose
this back as a question to you I was
going to read them The Diary of Anne
Frank and it just occurred to me should
we be reading an Frank's
diary do you know what I mean I mean it
had a there's a tiny lock on there for a
reason you guys and
um can you imagine my diary would be
banned from schools yeah I was thinking
that I was like can you imagine if you
had a diary and somebody's like hey we
have good news and bad news the good
news is you now have a best-selling
book the bad news is yeah everybody
knows that you think second cousins that
are hot don't
count I'm impressed that um I'm
impressed by Pink giving away uh books
books at her concert like that that
means she's doing well like I at my at
my shows I can't even give away
tickets
to my shows they said the first thousand
people get books at the concert and they
said if anybody is not um is not amongst
the first 1,000 you could find one in
the trash on the
floor to grab one so true it's so stupid
it's so true but this is what she needs
to do right because nobody this is the
first time I've heard about pink in ages
yes true you know true isn't it weird
too that like you ban a book but like if
my kid finds out that those books are
banned going to buy them they're not
burning them all and saying you can't
get them they're just saying like
they're sort of letting the parents
choose or letting some I don't know and
then when I heard pornography you could
you could read it I was like thank God
there's video
now I feel like reading porn reading
pornography that's that's an instance
where the movie is always better than
the book
yeah I never understood erotica no no
that was just weird yeah and then you
get all excited then you got to turn the
page and it goes
away all right enough of that up next is
it a crime to call 90s music the best of
all time hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else